buongiorno a tutti mi chiamo selene
biffi sono un'imprenditrice sociale dato
che non sono molto brava a parlare
insomma di massimi sistemi
spero che lei nel raccontarvi un po
quella che è stata la mia storia il mio
percorso professionale possiate trarre
magari degli spunti interessanti la mia
storia inizia in realtà ormai quasi
undici anni fa quando a 22 anni mi
ritrovo a pensare una cosa che secondo
me avrebbe potuto aiutare moltissime
persone l'idea è quella di costruire una
piattaforma una piattaforma internet che
in metodologia peer to peer e quindi da
giovane al giovane potesse dare
effettivamente tutte quelle conoscenze
teoriche ma anche pratiche ai ragazzi un
po sparsi per il mondo che volevano
attivarsi in prima persona nelle proprie
comunità
l'idea mi viene essenzialmente
partecipando alla conferenza torna in
italia e mi ritrovo a bussare un po
varie porte per sei mesi porta in
istituzione di ente di aziende di
università
l'idea è quella che insomma 22 anni non
avessi nelle competenze né tantomeno i
fondi per poter far partire una cosa di
questo tipo da sola quindi bussando a
varie porte la mia speranza era un po
quella che qualcuno si accorgesse di
considera che la facesse sua e che
fondamentalmente riuscisse un attimo a
tirare fuori una cosa mai vista prima
andavo a bussare a destra manca ma la
risposta era sempre un po quella dalla
parte mi si diceva no guarda a 22 anni
io non me la sento di investire se tu ne
va si tenta di più non sarebbe un
problema ma oggi proprio no diversamente
mi dicevano bella questa idea
sicuramente sarà la brutta copia di
qualcosa che già c'è in america in
inghilterra giusto nel rispondere no in
realtà siamo i primi a fare questo
lavoro ti dice vabbè allora mi pare di
fantascienza quindi no grazie comunque
parto con queste idee da solo ha poca
pazienza nella vita a gennaio 2005
decide di usare quello che avevo a
disposizione con 150 euro se volete il
prezzo di un paio di scarpe lancia youth
action for change un'organizzazione che
in pochissimo tempo arriva insegnare a
migliaia di ragazzi in 130 paesi del
mondo
95 per cento dei quali paesi in via di
sviluppo paesi in transizione
però c'è un punto di fondo che
c'è un for change è essenzialmente
gestita da 25 volontari tutti quanti
facciamo altri lavori per poterci
mantenere nel mio caso grazie a uno sta
già vent'anni di vento consulente per le
nazioni unite e mi occupo di tecnologie
per l'istruzione tecnologie per lo
sviluppo
un giorno mi viene chiesto di andare a
lavorare a kabul
qui viene chiesto andare a lavorare in
afghanistan su un progetto che con le
tecnologie non ha nulla a che vedere
mi viene infatti chiesto di andare a
stendere un sussidiario per i bambini
delle scuole elementari e specialmente
bambini che vivessero in zone rurali in
un paese che è dilaniato da quasi 35
anni di guerra e dove otto persone su
dieci sono analfabete forse del
sussidiario non è la cosa più utile ma è
veramente un progetto nazioni unite
quindi prendo la mia valigia mi
trasferisco kabul forse non tanto per
l'idea del del sussidiario ma per l'idea
di poter vedere un paese in transizione
un paese assolutamente molto
interessante
arrivo a kabul e mi rendo conto che si
fa le sussidiare carina interessante
però voglio dire qualsiasi persona
potrebbe farlo e potrebbe farlo
tranquillamente seduto comodamente a
casa non ha bisogno di essere in sede
mi rendo conto però che da lì a poco ci
sarebbero state le elezioni
presidenziali e stanno cercando
osservatori elettorali durante
l'università mi era capitato di fare
l'osservatore elettorale di organizzare
missioni in europa dell'est quindi mi
candido mi piace talmente tanto l'idea
che mi candido ben sette volte e quindi
candiani sette volte o quasi la certezza
che insomma il mio profilo fosse più
linea con l'osservazione elettorale che
non con la stesura del sussidiario ben
sette candidature tutte 7 rigettate
ovviamente ci rimango malissimo insomma
non me l'aspettavo
avevo forse da dare di più nell'ambito
dell'osservazione che non è quella di
una stesura di un libro
però questo ha fatto in modo che il mio
cammino deviasse il 28 ottobre 2009 il
mio mondo cambia perché un attentato
talebano
purtroppo va a individuare una guest
house il centro kabul dove moriranno 12
persone di queste due erano dei miei
colleghi tra le 114 guesthouse in uso
alle nazioni unite hanno preso l'unica
che in realtà era occupata dagli
osservatori elettorali quindi il libro
non volevo fare in qualche maniera ha
fatto in modo che il corso del mio
impegno professionale cambiasse vendeva
quota attorno in italia ci rimango tre
settimane decido di tornare finisco il
libro e rimarrò a kabul altri sei mesi
chiudendo il contratto torno in italia e
utilizza la mia indennità di missione
per aprire planning plain ink è
un'organizzazione che fondamentalmente
crea story fumetti educativi per
insegnare a bambini e comunità a trovare
le proprie soluzioni a problemi locali
legati alla povertà l'esclusione sociale
per tre anni lavoro in italia in india
ma la voglia di tornare a kabul e fare
qualcosa è più forte di tutto il resto
quindi sono tre anni di ricerca ricerca
fondi ricerca sponsor
finalmente arriva allo sponsor che in
questo caso rolex mi dà l'opportunità di
tornare in afghanistan quest'anno a
marzo per aprire una scuola una scuola
molto particolare una scuola per
cantastorie perché perché appunto
l'afghanistan è un paese con una
alfabetizzazione al 23 per cento e
quindi è difficile far passare concetti
a meno che non vengano raccontate in
forma orale questa scuola è attualmente
aperta insegna gratuitamente a ragazzi e
ragazze tra i 18 e 25 anni gli insegna a
scrivere storie che possano contenere
dimessa messaggi di sviluppo locale
quelli della salute pubblica
l'uguaglianza di genere per renderli più
fruibili e contestualmente rilevanti
tornare a kabul e aprire una scuola da
soli quindi senza le nazioni unite ma
come individuo che parte per nella sua
valigia si reca in un paese e deve fare
assolutamente tutto da reperire le
licenze per lavorare trovare una scuola
a trovare gli insegnanti tappezzare
kabul di poster per trovare gli studenti
insomma qui potete immaginare che non è
stato sicuramente facile abbiamo avuto
attentati abbiamo avuto autobomba
abbiamo dovuto non solo motivare chi
veniva a studiare ma motivare noi stessi
per cercare di andare avanti in un
contesto tanto difficile dove ovviamente
il fallimento non dico è sempre dietro
l'angolo però è molto più facile che non
avere successo
il mio coraggio in questo forse è stato
quello appunto di da una parte rifiutare
tre candidature al parlamento italiano
per andare a lavorare a kabul
gratuitamente ma non è questo che mi
interessava quello che mi interessava
grazie quello che mi interessava
fondamentalmente da fare un qualcosa che
suona che nessun altro aveva mai tentato
prima perché perché fondamentalmente per
me coraggio vuol dire motivazione
motivazione nello specifico vuol dire
non accontentarsi del pezzettino di
realtà che si ha di fronte quindi
cercare una via ulteriore per migliorare
le cose e cercare una modalità per fare
in modo che ci sia un cambiamento una
facilitazione affinché a questo
cambiamento
tutti quanti possono contribuire invece
pensare che non bisogna essere
necessariamente straordinari per fare
cose straordinarie ma la motivazione il
talento fanno sì che qualsiasi cosa vi
mettiate in testa di fare in realtà
diventi straordinaria la scuola kabul
sta appunto continuando e fra poco
avremo l'opportunità di fare modo che
che fa academy l'accademia delle storie
così è stata chiamata possa essere possa
diventare una scuola alla radio e quindi
da kabul distribuire le sue informazioni
fare lezione in tutto l'afghanistan
basta semplicemente ovviamente girare un
tasso questo perché perché la radio è
l'unico mezzo che ha una penetrazione
pari al 100 per cento tornata a casa mi
ritrovo nuovamente con l'idea di dover
cercare un qualcosa da fare questo
qualcosa da fare è nato recentemente si
chiama spillover è fondamentalmente fa
una cosa che anche in questo caso
riguarda l'istruzione l'istruzione non
formale nei prossimi sei anni abbiamo
2.8 milioni di posti di lavoro vacanti
in ambiti scientifici perché 60 per
cento dei ragazzi non piace la scienza
la ritiene astrusa astratta lontana non
mi piace mai considererebbe una carriera
in quell'ambito
questo ovviamente va a discapito di
quella che la competizione l'innovazione
e appunto va ad aumentare il divario
della disoccupazione
bene spiega over fa un po questo va
anche qui ad applicare la metodologia
delle storie dei fumetti dello story
telling prende tutto quello che ricerca
innovazione invenzioni direttamente dai
laboratori di ricerca dell'università e
ci crea intorno dei videogiochi per
ragazzini dai 10 ai 15 anni quindi con
l'intento di fare in modo che possano
cambiare la loro opinione possano
partecipare più attivamente prima che
l'opinione venga formata quindi intorno
ai 15 anni è rimasto pochissimo tempo e
vorrei concludere con un
zero che in realtà è un piccolo poema di
rumi un poeta afghano del xiii secolo
che fondamentalmente dice che non
bisogna accontentarsi delle storie che
sentite o di come le cose sono andati e
sono andate agli altri e la vostra di
leggenda che dovete scrivere quindi io
vi invito a non accontentarvi insomma
delle storie che sentirete oggi della
mia adesso recati sentito prima di
quelle che sentirete perché quello che
importa in fondo è la vostra di storia
grazie